Learn the skills of public speaking.
Point number five.
Point number six, to spread Islam to the
entire world. Masha'Allah. May Allah
make it possible through you.
Point number seven, to gain experience
from the best of the best orators.
That Allah knows
who's the best.
And may Allah not hold me responsible
for what the people say
and make me better than what people
expect.
Insha'Allah.
The next participant,
Zamri Vinod.
His first expectation is
to be a more effective da'ee.
Alhamdulillah.
He's a da'ee, he wants to be more
effective.
Alhamdulillah.
Insha'Allah, may Allah make it possible.
Expectation number two,
to memorize the evidences from various
scriptures.
Insha'Allah, we'll be dealing mainly
about the major religions.
That is
Christianity and Hinduism.
Christianity numbers is the most in
practice, Islam is number one.
Besides that, number three in the world
comes Hinduism. Mainly dealing with
these three religions, then a little bit
we'll be touching on Buddhism,
Jainism, as well as Sikhism. And a
separate day, this
is something additional we have kept, a
separate day only for da'wah to
atheists.
In the first few years, it was a small
session.
In this da'wah training program, there's
a full day
on dealing only with atheists.
Insha'Allah.
Grab the techniques of doing da'wah.
Insha'Allah, grab and retain and
implement, more important.
Implementation
is the most we'll do tomorrow,
Insha'Allah.
On forms of da'wah, retention,
implementation.
Number five, to serve back my country by
passing the knowledge that I learned
here.
Inshallah.
Hope the things that I learned here will
help me
to reach Jannah.
Inshallah.
If your near is there
and if you strive in the way of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala, Inshallah Allah will
open up your pathways.
Irrespective what the results are, your
near is more important. The results may
be phenomenal.
You know beloved prophet Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam said
that
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
the first people
who would enter the hellfire
are the Alims with their face dragged to
the floor.
Why?
Because they did it
for fame
and Allah said I gave you fame, now go
to hell.
Those who give charity, you did for
show, you got the praise, now go to
hell. So may Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
accept our efforts
that we do it with a pure near and the
pure intention to please Allah alone.
Last, seventh
to be humble die.
Humility is very important.
This
was a key factor
that created Iblis
ego.
So humility is very important which
Inshallah tomorrow we'll discuss that
in the characteristic of a die.
It's very important that you should be
humble.
Otherwise it can be the main cause of
your downfall.
Inshallah may Allah
fulfill all your seven expectations,
Inshallah.
Brother Shafiq
his seven expectations are to increase
and solidify my knowledge
in comparative religion.
Yes, it will teach you the basics.
But what you learn here
Inshallah
with this knowledge
you can even debate with the Pope.
Though it's not the whole knowledge
but the key points required for a person
to know
as As other religions are concerned,
it is sufficient.
Yes,
if you have more,
it's better.
But the key points, if you know it very
well,
the key.
Which is that discuss inshallah when we
deal with dawah to Christians, we'll be
planning 3 days on that. Dawah to
Hindus, 2 days.
Dawah to other religions, 1 day. And
dawah to atheists, 1 additional day.
Mastering the techniques, quoting from
various scriptures from Dr. Zakir Naik.
Inshallah, mastering is in your hand.
Mastering is in your hand
and Allah's help.
Inshallah.
Discovering other religions through
their own scriptures and original
sources.
Inshallah.
Point number four, to be a better and
efficient speaker of Islam. Inshallah,
may Allah make it possible.
Expectation number five, experience the
world of dawah on a professional
platform.
Inshallah, I always say
that professionalism is very important.
And
when we are there in the world of
specialization, always believe
do something which is
unique
or the best.
I believe in doing any project if I do,
which is I'll deal later on,
either should be unique
or it should be the best in the world.
You start with something unique and then
make it the best in the world,
inshallah.
Number six, to know Zakir Naik
personally and learn from his knowledge
and experience.
Hope it benefits. I don't know whether
meeting me or knowing me personally will
benefit or not. We pray to Allah that
benefits you, so then I get some reward.
Inshallah. To be a well-equipped guy.
Inshallah. We pray to Allah
that Allah fulfills all and many more of
your expectations, inshallah.
The next in my list is Firdaus Wong.
I'm there.
His first expectation is
to get closer to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Alhamdulillah, that's a good
expectation. That by becoming a da'ee
by doing this course,
he wants to get closer to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. If you pay
attention on the advice given,
inshallah,
it will get you closer to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
To study in depth about comparative
religion.
You will not be studying in depth about
comparative religion,
but
you will be knowing the basics what's
required.
For example, tell you frankly,
many people think Sheikh Deedat is Hafiz
of the Bible.
Myself, I knew Sheikh Deedat,
alhamdulillah, may Allah grant him
Jannah,
hardly knew a small percentage of the
Bible.
A very negligible percentage.
But what we know,
it gives the impression to the other
person, khalas.
That's the technique.
If you say you want to memorize the
Quran, alhamdulillah, what benefit do
you get by memorizing the Bible?
When you can get the achievement by
memorizing 1% of the Bible, why should I
waste my time memorizing 99%? Correct?
Yes, memorizing Quran, Hadith,
alhamdulillah. So, here we'll pay
emphasis on few verses, but memorize it
so well.
Few verses, 50, 100, not more than that.
Khalas.
You can debate with the Pope, also.
To master Christianity in particular. If
you can change it to
master doing da'wah to Christians,
better.
What benefit is for you to master
Christianity, tell me.
Answer.
So, you have to change your expectation.
Even I would not waste my time doing a
course of 10 years in Christianity, for
what?
When you can do it shortcut, you said,
no?
You can do it shortcut.
So, with Christianity, you even master
techniques with Hinduism or atheism,
da'wah.
So, expectation should not be to master
Christianity, your expectation should be
master
to do da'wah to the Christians.
So, that is
Yes.
I will tell you very frankly.
You are not going to master here
any other religion. Little bit
of Islam, yes. Not master that also.
You will not be mastering any religion.
That's a different question.
That your opponent, the person who is
debating you or the person asking you a
question
he will think 10 times before asking
question to you. If they ask anything
take out from your wallet, take out from
your pocket, take out verses.
That is his impression.
But you will not be mastering
because I don't want to waste my time
neither your time.
Is it clear?
You won't be mastering Christianity.
You'll be mastering inshallah how to
convey the message to Christians.
Inshallah. Point number four.
To improve
my memorization skills.
As far as
the memory is concerned
Allah has given
everyone a hard disk.
Hard disk capacity.
Instead of saying to improve my
memorization skills, yes, you can say
that.
The capacity is there.
How to utilize is more important. Proper
utilization of the hard disk is more
important.
And how fast to retrieve is more
That inshallah
in the course of the program if you
follow the guidance
you'll achieve to a great extent
inshallah.
And everything is with experience.
We'll show you the technique.
How well you implement it
how well you practice it is important.
Even if you do his.
Suppose you do his of the Quran.
If you don't do more than that
if you don't do revision it will leave
your memory.
You have to keep on revising.
It's unfortunate that most of the people
who do his
because they don't
revise, they forget.
More difficult than memorizing the Quran
is to retain is more difficult.
If you do a survey, you will find
mashallah throughout the world there are
hundreds of thousands of hafiz.
Millions.
But the people who can recite it
at any given time
is a small percentage of that. So,
that's a different technique.
And mashallah, we pay emphasis on that
in our school. They finish memorizing
the Quran by the time they reach
standard five.
And they do multiple revisions by the
time they finish school.
And inshallah, I will keep a session
of one of our hafiz.
The qari that recited today morning was
one of the teachers in our school.
Next time inshallah, after a few days or
a couple of weeks, we'll let you
interact with one of our hafiz of the
Quran.
Inshallah.
So, that you can
really come to know what is
memorization, inshallah.
To improve my public speaking skills.
Inshallah.
To explore the opportunity to share the
beauty and the true teachings of Islam
to global audiences.
Inshallah.
Once you do this course and if you
implement on it
and if you reach a level, inshallah.
Number seven, to be able to retain
minimum 70 to 80% of what I've learned
throughout the program by the end of the
training.
Alhamdulillah, that's a good
expectation.
To retain
minimum, at least
70 to 80% of what I've learned
through the program by the end of the
training, inshallah. We pray to Allah
that may he make you retain more than
that, inshallah.
And may he fulfill all the seven
expectations that you have.
La ilaha illallah.
La
ilaha illallah
Muhammadun Rasulullah
Allah
and Muhammad
have
and
Muhammad
and Muhammad and Muhammad